on va passer au témoin du jour on va
revenir sur la disparition très
mystérieuse de lina 15 ans qui reste
introuvable depuis samedi dernier
aujourd'hui de nouvelles informations
très inquiétantes ont été publiées le
nouveau détective qui a des informations
que seuls ont affirme que Tao le petit
ami de l'adolescente aurait menti sur
plusieurs points et aurait menacé Zoé
c'est ça restez avec vous parce que
c'est un truc de fou ce qui s'est que on
a eu une jeune fille qui s'appelait Zoé
qui travaillait avec Lina qui est venu
témoigner lundi et je vous jure que le
fait qu'elle soit venue ça a fait Gilles
tu vas nous confirmer avancer les choses
parce que en fait le copain on sait pas
ce qu'il en est encore mais
il aurait
été il aurait eu des mots très durs mais
envers Zoé et il aurait un peu menacé un
peu menacé et exaspéré dans un instant
avec Michel Marie c'est un truc de fou
et c'est vrai qu'elle est venue lundi et
ça rebondit justement derrière regardez
Thierry cap et Michel marie avec nous
c'est parti
[Musique]
la disparition de Lina c'est l'histoire
qui bouleverse les Français depuis
quelques jours depuis 15 ans que
personne n'a de nouvelles d'elle depuis
samedi après-midi plusieurs pistes sont
actuellement à l'étude et les fouilles
s'enchaînent pour tenter de retrouver
l'adolescente qui a disparu alors
qu'elle devait rejoindre Tao son petit
ami mais aujourd'hui l'hebdomadaire Le
nouveau détective détiendrait des
informations exclusives le concernant
alors quelles sont ses nouvelles
révélations Michel Marie qui a longtemps
collaboré avec le nouveau détective est
avec nous ce soir dans TPMP
bon merci Michel d'être avec nous on va
rappeler l'affaire pour les
téléspectateurs nous rejoindre il y a eu
des choses qui rebondit vous allez nous
dire où ça en aimer ça avance et c'est
pas des des très bonnes nouvelles gilet
Michel et c'est vrai que la venue
de Zoé lundi a fait rebondir les choses
et amener de nouveaux éléments pour le
moment on va rappeler l'histoire et
écoutez bien l'histoire parce que c'est
vrai quand vous nous avez parlé
d'histoire lundi il y a deux trois
petites choses qui ont fait ticket
notamment Jean-Michel et d'autres
personnes qui étaient chez eux
samedi 23
cette jeune fille Lina quitte son
domicile elle habite à la plaine c'est
un Tiamo un petit village pour se rendre
à la gare de sainte-blaise La Roche où
elle doit prendre le train à 12h03 pour
rejoindre son petit copain
Tao qui l'attend à Strasbourg
elle disparaît sur ce chemin et c'est
d'ailleurs le petit copain va me Tao qui
va donner le qui va donner l'alerte qui
va signaler à la famille de Lina que
Lina n'est pas arrivé à la gare de
Strasbourg et à partir de là la
gendarmerie va engager du personnel pour
faire des recherches on arrive à cibler
à peu près le l'endroit où enfin à
partir de quel endroit elle a disparu
c'est à dire entre la gare et une partie
du trajet qu'elle avait déjà fait je
crois qu'il lui restait 900 mètres à
parcourir pour arriver à la gare et
depuis elle s'est volatilisée de
nombreuses recherches ont été effectuées
ils ont les gendarmes ont
fondé pardon les les deux étangs enfin
plusieurs étangs ils ont organisé des
battues et pour l'instant toutes les
recherches sont restées vaines alors
justement ça rebondit depuis
une équipe de plongeurs de Strasbourg
ont réalisé des fouilles dans deux
étangs sans rien trouver Margot une amie
lina a dit qu'elle n'était pas comme
d'habitude elle était super contente de
la Strasbourg rejoindre son copain à
partir du moment où elle m'a dit je vais
partir d'un coup je n'ai plus de
nouvelles précises c'est ce qui a dit
Margaux d'habitude elle faisait beaucoup
de vocaux pour parler et là d'un coup
elle écrivait très rapidement c'était
très inquiétant et ce n'était pas comme
d'habitude on le sentait quand elle
parlait c'était très inquiétant parce
qu'elle mettait même des ponctuations
alors que d'habitude elles n'en mettait
pas forcément ce qu'elle dit Margot
c'est ça une des ce qui sous-entend que
c'est peut-être pas elle qui répondait
et qui utilisaient son téléphone
exactement alors vous allez voir comme
ça rebondit parce que il y a des
éléments qui sont arrivés qui sont quand
même assez troublant selon le point les
enquêteurs en sont sûrs Lina n'a pas
éteint la pâte l'étang du Bru ça c'est
sûr donc elle n'a pas il y a une caméra
installée près de ce plan d'eau privé
qui appartient à la société locale de
pêche qui a montré que l'adolescente n'a
pas passé les barrières derrière
lesquels se poursuit la piste cyclable
donc ça c'est un élément déjà on sait
Nina aurait donc disparu sur la route
départementale que vous l'avez dit entre
son domicile et l'entrée de la piste
cyclable ça représente combien de
kilomètres j'ai pas la distance il y a 2
km 9 entre son domicile et la gare et
lui restait 900 mètres à parcourir donc
alors il y a des révélations justement
du nouveau détecté vous êtes du nouveau
détective et le nouveau détective à
lâché plusieurs bombes sur leur site et
sur les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui on
va revenir point par point sur ce qu'ils
ont sorti plusieurs infos qui s'aiment
le doute sur le profil de Tao le petit
ami de Lina Tao à 19 ans il s'est
installé depuis peu à Strasbourg en tant
que Compagnon du Devoir qu'est-ce que
c'est quoi ça
va c'est
je sais pas exactement ce que c'est
c'est j'imagine que c'est un
c'est des artisans de très haut niveau
de très haut niveau
arriver au exceller dans leur métier
merci Jean-Michel merci alors il vient
de Marseille il s'est mis en couple avec
Lina
15 ans depuis début août début août donc
c'est assez récent
ça fait un peu plus d'un mois qui sont
ensemble et première info du nouveau
détective qui est assez troublante
on apprend que Tao le petit ami Lina
aurait perdu son téléphone dans une
usine désaffectée en cherchant Lina
l'appareil serait moins
longcontreusement tombé dans une bouche
d'égout alors à côté de nous c'est
effectivement ce qui ressort de
l'enquête de ma consœur Sixtine le père
elle a elle est sur place elle est
toujours sur place et elle a fait une
enquête une bonne enquête une belle
enquête et elle a retrouvé des témoins
et notamment elle a cette information
il aurait participé
Tao en réparticipé aux recherches et à
l'occasion de ces recherches il serait
monté sur le toit d'une usine des
affectée et alors qu'il était en haut de
ce toit son téléphone serait tombé
malencontreusement dans le soupirail
dans un soupirail il y a cinq points
vous allez voir un qui pose problème le
premier donc c'est la même mystérieuse
perte du téléphone j'ai dit pourquoi le
téléphone est essentiel et ça perte
fondamentale là c'est important c'est
parce que le petit ami dit qu'il est
parti donc du domicile de la maman de
Lina et chez Lina au matin il va à
Strasbourg il attend à 12h53 à
Strasbourg sur le quai selon lui Lina
elle n'arrive pas et c'est lui qui
téléphone à la maman pour lui dire je
suis inquiet Lina n'arrive pas donc ce
téléphone il doit à ce moment-là borner
à Strasbourg pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
pas un hasard incroyable une coïncidence
qui fait que alors que on va savoir aux
bornes ce téléphone et bien lui dit
qu'il le perd donc les enquêteurs encore
une fois il y a pas du tout de il est
pas du tout mis en cause pour le moment
mais les enquêteurs vont vouloir savoir
si au moment où il appelle la maman il
est bien à Strasbourg c'est ça voilà
mystérieuse perte du téléphone c'est le
premier point très très important il y a
5 oui ça le fait que le téléphone soit
tombé n'empêche pas de borner le service
de police ou de gendarmerie de de voir
le bornage en revanche pardon en
revanche on n'a pas le contenu des SMS
c'est ça qui est plus embêtant si je
peux me permettre l'expression donc le
téléphone disparaît on sait
on arrive à retrouver de façon très
précise les horaires des échanges qui
appelle qui
qui décroche qui décroche pas et où sont
les différents protagonistes
c'est-à-dire où se trouve Lina et où se
trouve Tao sur ce premier point qui a 5
points très important il y a un point
qui est important quand la procureur
s'est exprimée très rapidement elle a
détaillé les fêtes etc et elle a dit
donc Tao avait appelé depuis Strasbourg
la maman pour dire que Lina n'était pas
arrivée elle n'a pas dit en Verbatim
intégrale que Tao était sur le quai de
la gare donc pour le moment pour le
moment les enquêteurs comme il y a de la
vidéo surveillance à la gare Strasbourg
vont examiner voir s'il était bien sur
le quai à l'heure qu'il indique voilà
deuxième point très important et à 5
points qui pose problème là autour de
Tao le petit ami de Lina après voilà
pour l'instant il y a rien de fait mais
on va vous donner les 5 points selon une
autre source Tao aurait affirmé avoir
participé à une battue avec un certain
Bryan un ami de Lina et visiblement ce
serait faux c'est un mensonge qui a son
importance alors c'est embêtant d'autant
que Bryan et très proche de Zoé qui est
venu sur ce plateau effectivement Tao
affirmé avoir participé à une battue et
dit qu'il était aux côtés de Brian et
Bryan quand il est entendu dit que il
n'a pas de souvenir d'avoir vu Tao alors
ça peut être dans la confusion dans
l'adresse mais ça commence à faire quand
même un sapin voilà potentiellement son
jeu de Tao troisième point
le jour de sa disparition Lina ne devait
rejoindre Tao que le soir mais au petit
matin changement de plomb Taho aurait
appelé la mère de Lina pour lui demander
de la réveiller pour qu'elle prenne le
train et le rejoignent ça c'est un point
c'est incroyable là on comprend plus
hein
il est il habite à Strasbourg il y a un
passé la soirée à la plaine en compagnie
donc de Lina il passe la soirée ensemble
ils dorment ensemble il part très tôt
pour un mystérieux rendez-vous
il est convenu qu'il se retrouve le soir
donc elle a toute la journée pour faire
ce qu'elle a à faire prendre le train et
le rejoindre dans la soirée à Strasbourg
et là changement de programme pour des
raisons qui m'échappent il appelle la
maman donc Fanny la maman de Lina en
lisant réveiller votre fille il faut
qu'elle prenne le train il faut qu'elle
me rejoindre rapidement à Strasbourg et
c'est ce que la maman va faire elle
réveille sa fille et ensuite c'est comme
ça que la fille que Lina va prendre la
route à pied la fameuse D350 là pour se
rendre à la gare et elle disparaît sur
le sur le trajet donc on comprend pas
pourquoi ce changement de programme
quel est ce rendez-vous mystérieux à 7h
du matin l'oblige à partir à 7h du matin
et pourquoi tout modifier c'est encore
deux points qui pose problème je voulais
donner dans un instant Gilles par
rapport à ce troisième point j'ai au
contraire de c'est nous ce qui sont sur
place me disait qu'il y a une quand même
Tao il s'exprimait beaucoup et à plein
de gens il a dit oh là là ce weekend on
a un programme extrêmement chargé on a
plein de choses à faire etc il
détaillait un peu d'une manière
inconsidérée et les gens comprenaient
pas pourquoi tout un programme de
week-end comme si c'était un programme
fondamental alors qu'il y avait rien de
très important donc les gens se sont dit
c'est bizarre de détailler comme ça un
programme pourquoi est-ce qu'il fait ça
voilà quatrième point qui pose problème
et ça nous concerne
en apprenant que Zoé la collègue de Lina
allait témoigner dans TPMP ta polio Tao
lui aurait dit fais gaffe si tu dis de
la merde
et il paraît qui voilà c'était un peu
chaud qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
exactement ce que vous venez de dire
Zoé a révélé que Tao l'avait entre
guillemets pas c'est pas forcément faut
voir enfin c'est toujours très délicat
de de parler pour les autres mais ça
existait cette il a décroché son
téléphone et il l'a entre guillemets moi
je prends dans les patins je dis qu'il
la menacé mais c'est une menace j'ai dit
pas de la merde fais gaffe c'est une
menace donc cette jeune fille est venue
et courageusement elle a incroyable elle
a expliqué son amitié avec avec Lina
avec beaucoup d'émotion elle a rien dit
de
elle connaît pas en fait elle est comme
tout le monde elle ne sait pas ce qui
s'est passé
c'est vrai que c'est curieux que que ce
jeune homme alors soit il est très
maladroit
soit il y a autre chose on voit pas ce
qui peut le gêner dans le témoignage si
ce n'est si ce n'est que Zoé elle est là
à la sortie du travail à 19h le vendredi
quand la voiture de Tao vient chercher
Lina donc est-ce que lui se dit elle va
dire que j'étais là elle va préciser des
choses et ce qu'il a peur de son
témoignage et ce qu'il ne est-ce qu'il
craint que Zoé en dise plus aux
enquêteurs voilà en tout cas c'est
agressivité bizarre aujourd'hui
ça c'est même pas de la présomption
d'innocence c'est qu'il est pas du tout
mis en cause simplement
il y a des mecs
du tout exactement il y a des faits que
l'on explose voilà selon le cinquième
point selon le reporter de nouveaux du
nouveau détective sur place les
gendarmes ont quitté précipitamment le
restaurant où il se trouvait suite à
après un coup de téléphone cet
après-midi sur monter en vitesse dans
leur véhicule et ont quitté les lieux
pour retourner sur la RD 350 le chemin
sur lequel Ina disparu donc ils c'est un
truc de fou
aujourd'hui ils ont une info ils ont été
appelés ils sont partis au gyrophare de
ton Giraud
et a priori ça n'a pas euh on a
l'impression que les gendarmes font
semblant de continuer les fouilles pour
ne pas trahir le fait qu'ils ont qu'ils
aient déjà un suspect sérieux dans le
viseur ou une voilà une personne
possible c'est tout à fait possible
maintenant moi je rappelle quand même
que il y a une série de coïncidences qui
cible
un individu ça arrive que c'est pas la
personne aussi mais c'est pas bon parce
que il y a cette série de coïncidences
que pour autant ça en fait il a pas été
effectivement placé en garde à vue pour
l'instant ça va il sera entendu très
vraisemblablement il a déjà été entendu
mais il sera probablement rien entendu
et on verra on verra bien mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a quand même une série de
coïncidences troublante alors juste ce
rebondissement cet après-midi
voilà les gendarmes se sont précipités
comme s'ils avaient venaient avoir une
info oui parce que il y a eu un appel à
témoin qui suffit des dizaines des
centaines de témoignages de gens qui
n'ont rien vu et c'est important aussi
parce qu'ils ont ils ont dit nous on
était là et on l'a pas vu passer à tel
endroit donc ils sont en train de
raccourcir les lieux et de voir à quel
moment elle aurait pu monter dans une
voiture parce que c'est la thèse qui
prédomine pas d'accident la fugue avec
le battage si jamais c'était volontaire
on suppose c'était pas son genre mais
qu'elle se serait manifesté donc elle
est sans doute montée dans une voiture
la telle fait volontairement ou a-t-elle
été contrainte et donc il tente de
savoir sur la route où elle aurait pu
monter dans la voiture et de chercher
partout des indices voilà parce que ce
qui est important c'est que justement
quand elle est montée dans la voiture si
elle est montée dans une voiture on lui
aurait demandé immédiatement d'éteindre
son téléphone c'est à ce moment-là c'est
comme ça de 11h22
sans lui imposer d'éteindre son
téléphone soit il y a eu on peut
supposer tout ce qu'on veut
merci en tout cas Michel est-ce que vous
avez d'autres choses à ajouter non non
pour revenir au départ précipité des
gendarmes vu par notre porteur dans un
restaurant je crois
ça arrive souvent sur les gros faits
divers ce qui fait il y a une vraie
tension et un coup de fil de
l'état-major un coup de fil du patron on
sent que l'enquête avant et ils mettent
parce qu'on avait dit la dernière fois
sur Internet et le lendemain il y a eu
le dénouement nous ce qu'on aimerait
c'est qu'on retrouve Lina vivante et que
sa mère a retrouvé vivante parce que
elle vit des moments très très compliqué
on pense fort à sa maman vraiment je me
mets à sa place et je pense à elle tous
les jours en tout cas et voilà il faut
qu'il reste forte et qu'elle garde
espoir merci à vous tout de suite les
Mitra un peu